[Music]
okay
lawrence yes sir um so where are you
from where do you grow up uh i grew up
in charleston south carolina um it's
where i
graduated high school went to college um
played football all that fun stuff and
you grew up with your parents yes sir
yeah
how was your childhood um it was pretty
good for the most part i originally
lived in uh columbia
south carolina which is uh like 100
miles away
and that's where i went to middle school
and i i
shifted over to charleston and um it's
when i first realized you know like what
a beach was for the most part
and uh man-made beaches as well it's
pretty cool yeah
your childhood was cool everything was
great you're about to go along with both
parents yes sir yeah yeah my uh my dad
worked a lot he um he would work late in
late shifts
so uh he never really got a chance to go
to most of the football games but i mean
he was there he'd make it
and uh
what did you read when he left home
oh
you guys was 17 turning 18. yeah
something like that where'd you go
um i moved into a friend's house he was
he had a full-time job his own vehicle
and his own apartment
and so
i went from crashing at his pad to uh
paying him some cash
to live there
you know give him like 200 bucks a month
i didn't really know like the true
meaning of you know taking care of
myself
you know so
i i didn't hold up the end of my bargain
it wasn't until uh we all started
hanging out together
and came together as like a crew and
we'd help each other out
and
so you come to l.a at what point
um
man i moved out here [ __ ]
2005 6 7 2000
2010
are you going to hear us right now yes
sir yeah i've been here for [ __ ] like
seven six seven years was that right yes
sir
what uh
what's your what's your drug out here
man i like a little bit of everything um
you know la's notorious for their chris
but um
i don't know the weed shops
have uh they have everything
you know from everywhere so that's a
really good choice um
i don't know i don't really
mess around with any of the other stuff
around here it's kind of bogus
or it's difficult to find
so what your main
drug is what chris
yeah probably chris yeah
everybody does it it's um
and nobody frowns upon it
are you still in contact with your uh
your family
from time to time yeah uh we've actually
grown to spread apart this last uh
two years or so it's been kind of
extremely distant
i've uh
contacted them only a handful of times i
don't know
um for some reason i don't know this is
yeah this past two years have been kind
of distant
with uh did you have any kids of your
own
yeah yeah i've been i've been newborn
you have one child yeah
where is he or she um she's uh she's
with her mom
and they they live here in l.a
do you see her are you there no i'm not
in contact with them
we um
[Music]
you know i kind of like i lost contact
with them
i guess
you know
and i haven't i haven't talked to my
family either
and
i'm sure they don't have anything to say
so
i don't what are you doing for money now
i don't have any money right now i've uh
i i just got all my money stolen from me
somebody uh
tapped into my ebt card as soon as i got
it
and took all my cash and my card
and um they set up at the office i have
to file claim police report and
nine out of 10 times
that they even if they do
uh pursue
that i'm only gonna get my cash
and
that's you know it's it's not it's still
not
it's not fair
yeah that kind of stuff happens here a
lot if they pursue and most of the time
they don't so
no it's just it's
but in general what do you do for money
it's extremely difficult to get work
around here um recycling
uh fortunate enough for me i know
the
late night recyclers so that if i miss
in the morning time
that i can go at night and cash out and
we still have money
get something to eat
but even that is uh
extremely difficult in competition with
everybody else like
you know when you when you go to pick
cans everybody uh they nowadays we leave
the cans the the doors to the the trash
cans open
so the next person can see
you know and uh
you see one trash can [ __ ] up and
there goes your route for the night
you know because he's one step ahead of
you
yeah man that [ __ ] happens so
um
usually i would walk from downtown
to macarthur park and between downtown
and macarthur park
i would collect averagely speaking ten
dollars
worth of cans
and um that's just enough it fills up
everything one whole cart maximum
it's 10 bucks
how old are you
i'm 30. i'm about to be 31 in january um
i had
i had plans
um
honestly since um
since everything happened
and um
it being extremely difficult to find
work
i've been living life
the maximum
bump status
just
not that i don't give a [ __ ]
and but
i'm absolutely not wasting any effort on
anything
until it's time
and at that point then i'll take a step
forward in the right direction whatever
direction that is
but until then not very like i'm not
going on
crazy
mission side missions gonna be
uh redirected misinterpreted i'm just
gonna sit back and chill
all right well mark thank you so much
for talking to me yeah man for sure
i'm careful thank you thank you